on this episode I'm going to talk about
Lizzy's impact on my career my health
and talent do have it
everybody this is the askgaryvee show
and I'm your host gary vay-ner-chuk and
I'm excited to fire away with five new
questions on Episode four fun fact about
the number four that was Brett Favre's
number as a New York J diligent leaders
asks in terms of platform social media
is it better to self brand or establish
a name brand I go back and forth build
your leaders that's a solid question you
know I think it's something everybody
struggles with it you know am I gonna be
Gary Vaynerchuk on social or am I gonna
be like wine marketing man look what
happened there that's my answer what
happens if you evolve a lot of people
watching right now started off as
marketing gurus but now sell you know
carrot juice one of the things I like
about being your name is that you can
evolve with it
you're looking at a guy who used to do a
show where I drank wine and spit into
the bucket and now I'm doing this show
and I've a been able to do a seamless
transition because the truth is many of
us many of us have different facets to
our personalities and so I am of the
camp of going with your name it's
something that can stick with you
there's consistency you don't have to
rebrand I didn't have to change my
Twitter profile from wine guy to ask guy
Blake asks how important is it that your
significant other share your
entrepreneurial vision what was Lizzie's
impact on building your empire Blake
this is a great question I excited to
get your question on the show um you
know first of all Lizzie's impact on my
career is much more than I expected you
know I grew up and would hear things
like behind every great man is a great
woman I'd like to and not in a negative
like chauvinistic way but like I was
like I'm hustling my face off like I'd
be working every hour and then you start
growing and you mature and and you
become a man not a kid and the truth is
I'm actually flabbergasted by the level
of Liz's impact on my career Lizzie's
kind of support and I mean like utter
100,000 percent support is like a major
factor it gives me the headspace to be
all in here at Vayner and doing
I thing versus worrying about like if
I'm five minutes late you know I'm
running late
taping this right now if I get home like
it's you know it's incredibly important
in the fact if you prioritize your
career curveball you know so it's
massively important to give you
headspace to have you know as much
freedom to execute on your vision
professionally but the truth is when you
fall in love with somebody that person
needs to take you know precedent over
everything else and so at some level if
you don't have that well you know that
just comes with the consequences of love
and and and that's okay too you may not
be able to hustle or work on it or work
on it in a clear mind space and never
give it a hundred percent I'm able to
give 100 percent devotion to my
businesses for enormous amounts of time
every day because of Lizzie and the way
she rules and supports some people can
only put 73 percent of their time for a
shorter period of time and they're going
to have limited success in comparison
predicated on our talent as well because
talent is a variable so it's massively
important for success but it's not the
only thing is it Ryan asks what's the
most common mistake you see founders
make building a consumer focused
business right uh there's so many
goddamn mistakes in building a consumer
business but I will tell you the you
know you asked the question I'm gonna
have to keep it real here as we do on
hashtag askgaryvee show
the biggest mistake I see is that it is
really really hard to build a consumer
app the ability to beat out everybody
else in the world in making something
sticky that people care about right is I
don't know why did that is extremely
difficult and the biggest mistake I see
Ryan is actually the fact that people
don't have talent to actually execute a
consumer product that the audacity the
audacity in the marketplace right now by
the young and hungry and the old and
hungry in thinking that I'm going to
make this app and it's going to work is
so ludicrous to me it's so
Oh stunning to me
you have people who've been career
students you have people that have been
career corporate American people and
they think they're gonna just come and
start a product and understand the
behavior of the end consumer better than
anybody else trying to scratch that itch
for that specific product that takes
special talent nobody wakes up ins like
I'm gonna be an NBA player today cuz
just it just makes sense to them
but everybody right now is waking up and
saying they're going to be a consumer
product innovator inventor co-founder
and so the truth is the answer to your
question straight up is lack of self
awareness that they're not good enough
to do it
Marie asks what's the biggest lesson
you've learned this year Marie that is a
very simple question by far the biggest
question that biggest question the
biggest thing I learned don't edit it I
don't add it here Marie the biggest
thing I've learned this year
hands down is that prioritizing my
health is a really good idea the fact
that I am now going to the gym and
eating healthy and I'm 21 we Tuesday say
Tuesday so I'm 26 days in 226 days of
working out and times 378 healthy meals
in a row without cheating the energy
level is actually down believe it or not
because I was living on sugar but I just
feel like a totally different person it
was the absolute right decision for me
it's changed my life I'm heading in the
right direction I feel like a different
person I would be on this earth longer
for it barring crazy accident and I uh
I'm happy about that Daniel asks what's
the best advice you can give salespeople
in social media
dee gordon would sell my friend just
want to give you one more shout out for
that time we hung out years ago at your
family's business I enjoyed it thanks
for the question biggest piece of advice
that I'm willing to give to salespeople
in this world is actually ironically the
jab jab jab right hook it's cliche I
think you guys know where I would go
with this I mean the truth is
everybody's trying to close too early
it's just lack of patience
it's not providing value why in the
world am i doing this show is it that I
missed the limelight of a Daily Show by
the way this will not be a daily show
just to just to kill any lack of
confusion I'm going away in two weeks of
my family unlike Wine Library TV days
where I would tape 10 episodes that will
not be happening you'll be missing me at
the end of August but I will come back
with gusto in September it's because I
want to provide value it's because I
could be regurgitating the same old
stuff that I believe in core principles
or I could go to this format and give me
value on a daily basis on things that
you're looking for and so you know to me
a couple things one understand Facebook
dark posts the segmentation is
incredible to Twitter search you can
pull people out one by one three
LinkedIn's coming soon with their
product where you'll be able to focus
based on titles so you can hit up every
single person that's a CFO of a
financial service company in their
stream that's the hit up not spamming
them in the mail on LinkedIn so be
cacked achill but understand the
religion right which is provide value
upfront how many of you who watch this
show provide value put out Sporty's
entertainment free stuff reply to people
and aren't just hitting up people who
have more followers or more exposure
than you to try to get exposure to
yourself how many of you are trying to
actually provide value thank you so much
for watching episode 4 of the askgaryvee
show now here's something that's
important to me I've been pushing this
as you guys know on my Instagram the
links and the bio on Twitter a bunch I
don't like how hard I have to throw
right hooks to establish the base so
everybody who's watching I need you to
subscribe up subscribe up subscribe up
subscribe up square sup clap Subscribe
up because this way you'll actually get
it delivered and you know when the show
will air every time it comes out so in
my mission to not bother you too much I
need you to subscribe up you with a
little bit of me we are changing the QA
world whether they like it or not that
was Brett Favre's number as
New York Jack oh look at something real
quick and it was I'm like literally up
the lip this up and I was in and out for
two seconds I'm pretty sure glad I hit
news images I'm gonna be any jet freakin
photos about barb okay let's go you've
got this is definitely credit on this
episode I talk about my pops I feel
someone direct me in the face for scrap
questions and I really focus on small
businesses should be doing it seem busy